moi je ne suis plus la vente de 6
pendant la pandémie
hubert et flavie au passé beaucoup de
temps à dessiner et comme par
enchantement un de leurs dessins été
choisi pour illustrer la version
française de l'icca bogue de jk rowling
j'étais plus calmes et bien content
j'étais super content j'étais vraiment
content même si en même temps un tout
petit peu déçu que ça soit juste un
petit clip
le dessin de flavie est une pâte 10k
bogue hubert d'huy a dessiné un chasseur
des cas bogue une créature créée par du
curling cinq ans qu il ya un monstre
j'avais mika veulent aller j'en dis que
c'est vraiment terrifiant ils mangent
les maps
moi je me suis pas ennuyé une seule fois
par un copain
les premières traces de l'icca bogues
sont apparues sur internet au mois de
mai dernier pour réconforter les enfants
c'est en est certain l'auteur de harry
potter a mis en ligne son histoire puis
elle a lancé un concours pour trouver
les illustrateurs de chaque chapitre de
la version papier juste pas neutre alors
quand j'ai envoyé des singes étaient
convaincus qu'à décaler gagne mais c'est
ça que c'est moi office donc c'est ce
que j'aime ce parti-pris pas qu'on avait
pas les ventes les mêmes souffrent
encore que ça l'est vraiment existé
s'avérer très loin j'attendais depuis sa
wii
en plus de voir leurs dessins publiés
qu'hubert et flavie ont reçu une copie
autographié de l'icca bonnes affaires et
leur école recevra une montagne de
livres estimé à près de 800 $ tête j'ai
photocopié ça c'est être précis dont m
après laventure de l'icca bogues flavie
et hubert n'entend pas rangé leurs
crayons et il n'écarte pas la
possibilité d'en faire une carrière si
ce quelque chose rien alors je
trop tard et il sera temps voilà c'est
dit jk rowling n'a qu'à bien se tenir
cette signature est ici louis philippe
ouimet radio canada morial